[Music]
[Music]
good morning a bachelor nation thank you
so much for joining us on ET live with
all of our roses i'm lauren zima
we are here with Kristin Kristin thank
you for being here Kristin the first
contestant from Becca kufran season 2
grace our recaps this is very exciting
I feel special you're gonna tell us
everything guys I have so many questions
for Kristin and I'm sure that you do too
so leave it your comments and questions
across our social platforms I will get
them here on our iPad and we're gonna
dive right in talk about last night's
episode talk about really the whole
season because you're our first you're
your first insight rackets are very
exciting let's dive right in with this
talk to me about watching the show back
who is maybe the most different seeing
the episodes like are you seeing things
you didn't see before and you're like
that guy was not who I thought he was
you know what I mean when you start to
see stuff who is that for you ah well I
mean it was a few guys you know because
we didn't get to see you know the
one-on-one times with Becca you know
obviously group dates everyone talks
about it but guys maybe boast a little
bit hey I spent some great one-on-one we
we connected then you go back and you're
like no you guys did you know I would
say a few of the guys were you know it
kind of surprised me I think John Blanc
he was one of the guys he was actually
you know one of the guys I was I was
cool with in the house break you know we
he thought he had the connection and he
didn't so do you think he really thought
he had the connection I mean I was
watching it and I'm like there's no way
this dude thinks this is real is he just
you know he's caught up in the moment
maybe when he told her and if you guys
remember Jean Blanc loved the Cologne
and then he told her he made her a
special perfume and that he was falling
in love with her but then he like took
the perfume back and said no I just said
that yeah that was a moment where I just
felt like this guy got caught up in
everything yeah but if he got caught up
on me he I got the first I think date
rose so you know that could have said a
lot and maybe he took that
with it from there but you know a lot of
relationships to build really quickly
and now so you know maybe farther than
he was but I would imagine it's hard I
mean I talked to so many of you guys but
still I just think when you're in it you
it's in many ways a social experiment
like was being on the show what you
thought that it would be no I mean I I
really didn't know what to expect so
everything was new for me it was a
different a different experience a
different world in I mean you know when
you look to play back you're like man I
really say that
what was I thinking during this time
because it's it's it's a different world
it's a different a different animal yeah
did you come across the way that you
thought you would for the most part I
feel like I guess I was actually
pleasantly surprised how you know how I
look back at to them like well that's
something I probably would have done and
that's probably how I wasn't thinking so
many athletes on your season you're a
former Globetrotter right
we had clay who played football plays
football and unfortunately got injured
we had oh I'm blinking now but I feel
like there's somebody else Oh Colton
Walton hi Colton and it was so
unfortunate that clay did get her were
you guys like blown away by that I mean
he really just had about yeah I was so
like I was actually very shocked I mean
he's the football player I think he got
injured like he is yeah I know what can
go wrong will go wrong so but you know
clay is a good guy you know he I think
he made a really good connection with
Beca but he had to do what's best for
him and then I know and he was it was
breaking my heart with how much sure he
was being about that whole thing is like
as a man you have to make decisions like
yeah yeah so I hope we see clay on our
TV screens again so let's talk about
last night's episode and we'll pepper in
some things from the rest of the season
I want to start with the guy who I just
forgot I'm so sorry : if you're watching
I adore you Colton so him and Beca get a
one-on-one where they ride on camels and
we got our first hot tub in the desert
moment of the season which I just love
when we have a hot tub in the middle of
nowhere and Colton has been somebody who
on the one hand you're watching it and
thinking like this guy seems so nice
seems so great but of course he has a
little bit of controversy surrounding
him with the whole Tia thing what was
that like in the house like how much did
you know about his past with Tia and
what
everybody think of it well you know
there were conversations floating around
about the Tia situation so I mean we
knew a little bit here and there it was
just unraveling throughout the time we
were there so every day was just
something new and so it was always like
a story with Conan we were all guessing
at the same time so now we're seeing
this you know watching the playback
you're like oh wow wow so I'm actually
you know I'm actually tuned in to seeing
hearing more about it so you didn't
really know the full story when you were
in the house no a lot of stuff was kept
under wraps
you know Colton he was very private
about it he kept his conversations with
Becca and you know I mean he didn't
spread too much but you know where it
gets out a little bit and we all were
kind of asking and trying to figure it
out well let me just ask you what you
think of it because this has been a big
topic of conversation amongst fans is he
there for the right reasons as we say
because even Tia said when she came on
that spa date she said well I think he
dated me thinking I might become the
Bachelorette so people are like is
Colton inda Becca was he into Tia did he
just want to be on the show right what
do you think well I mean Cole I mean
from my standpoint he seemed like he's
there for the right reasons he he made a
strong connection with Becca and it's
all about what Becca likes at the end of
it you know and it's the reason we're
all here and if she finds that
connection then that's that's great I
think Becca is very attracted to Cole
yeah she really seems really into him
like the chemistry yeah from at least
from the one-on-one they seem like
they're really hitting it off oh yeah I
think she has said he's easy on the eyes
and I'm like hey you know when you spend
so little time with people and you're
still figuring it all out you got to
maybe you're like I'm really attracted
to this guy personality-wise I'm
connecting with this guy and we'll see
where it goes from here exactly
okay so do you still talk to Colton like
are you guys friends and I mean whoa I
mean called we're cool there's a good
guy yeah we worked out together a few
times it yeah he's been out here in LA
okay
all right comments coming in and Jessica
on Facebook says I've been wanting Chris
done and I got Kristen with a bunch of
heart.i emojis and high-fives Jessica
thank you for your enthusiasm we're very
happy he's here Sarah says on YouTube
who was your closest friend from the
season and who is your top pick now this
is an interesting question because I
think there's always a difference will
hope first will answer who is your
closest friend my closest friend on the
sea
I have to go a will I love I love wills
yes Will's was my roommate to be there
so it was cool and he was the best cook
in the house by far that's one thing
that we have yet to see yeah he was a
really good cook I hope that he has some
kind of date where he cooks Rebecca I
love them I have to say there's been a
lot of you know there were a lot of
athletes it was a lot of like showing
her how to you know play this sport of
this sport so I'd love to see a little
bit oh now I'm gonna cook for you back I
love that um we don't have a clip from
wills but I'm regretting it not pulling
one because that plaid suit he was
wearing last night yeah that was what a
moment wills I mean you might become the
sixth member of clear eye and just show
everybody how to dress his great style
he's so nice and I loved the way that he
was just being not into Chris's drama
like were you watching that thinking was
he way more frustrated than he was
letting on in that Chris moment I
believe he was actually you know he was
being himself he was trying to hold back
a little bit because you know we all
have to get our time with Becca and so
he was it was fun he waited his turn and
now he's like alright I'm not like about
the losers B time damn because I'll give
you two minutes so I definitely
understand what he was coming from
I felt like Chris was being a little bit
like being immature in that moment
frankly because his whole issue was well
he didn't care about making the time for
Becca before and then he wanted his time
and he wanted it right now and he didn't
care if he had to move wills out of the
way to make that time happen I don't
know I don't dislike Chris it just felt
like he got caught up in the drama and
he needed to take a step off of that
training yeah do you what do you expect
for Chris I mean he was also in the room
with us as well so I mean no disrespect
to him but I felt like he you said he
got caught up in the drama and it just
got the best couple it is so is that was
last night's episode not reflective of
Chris as a whole well I don't feel like
it was a reflection of Chris but I mean
you can you really have to make your
time worth loud and you can't get too
caught up in the drama and now you're
losing that conversation with Becca that
you really want to have so watching
wills and Becca how are you feeling
about their connection I feel like it's
a most like this he's like a sleeper you
know you're 30 guys he's like a dark
horse yeah exactly
and you know he's being himself and he's
he's like a mellow guy so I'm thinking
Becca's really uh feeling huh well when
you're getting the interactions she's
getting with Jordan and David and Chris
she's wills is probably just a breath of
fresh air yeah I mean I loved him on the
one-on-one he was he really strut when
he was coming over that hill I he was
really struggling in the snow I thought
he was gonna fall over at one point but
he just laughed it off and he was chill
he's chill Wells and then Sarah had also
said who is your top pick so this
question to me can always go one of two
ways
it can be who do you think Becca's
should pick and who do you think she
does pick and tell me who you think she
should pick but also who like you see
her having the strongest pull - is it a
different a different person one of the
other well yeah I mean you can obviously
obviously see what Becca who she's
gravitating to I mean you have people
like cold and Garrett and Gary had the
first impression Blake I felt like Blake
had a great one-on-one date with her
like that was like something and I think
he caught her his girlfriend at one
point is it that you feel like you're my
girlfriend I was like okay Blake is and
he's not getting caught up in things
either he's actually been stepping away
and yourself and he's uh he's been a
quiet guy but he's definitely broken one
thing um well let's talk a little bit
about Garrett because I gotta ask you
about this there's been obviously
controversy surrounding Garrett and his
Instagram scandal I'm sure you guys know
but if you don't Garrett basically
released a statement saying yes he had
liked some very controversial memes on
Instagram saying he doesn't want his
social media to reflect who he is and
that he's learning from the whole
situation
so tell me knowing Garrett were you
surprised by everything that kind of
came out about that you know very
surprised but at the same time I spent
time with him in the house and he's very
funny very genuine guy I feel like he
the reason he he he started his
Instagram / he ended up making a whole
new page and just apologizing for what
he did I felt like he'd learned this
lesson and the shows he's a bigger
person and he's in the public eye no he
has to be mindful that because those
things can be offensive to people in you
know I feel like well you know he's
learned to listen well it would I mean
it was a bummer to see because
you know we're liking Garrett on the
show we know Becca's liking him and it's
a bummer that it's it was all happening
would you have thought like knowing
Garrett in the house and talking to him
would you have thought this would have
happened about him like did you ever see
him say or do stuff like that or was it
just I definitely didn't know I didn't
see any of this I mean a lot of the guys
were all pretty cool
we all you know we've built relationship
the bromance in the house was pretty
cool so um I mean it was something that
I didn't see coming and I was actually
shocked by it but you know we'll see how
it unravels at the men talk
mara says I love that he said wills she
loves will Zachary and you know while
we're talking about it let's talk a
little bit about Lincoln cuz that's been
another issue we saw Lincoln barely any
on the show last night just for a minute
on this Wayne Newton songwriting date
but Lincoln you know it's come out that
he was arrested for indecent assault on
a woman and convicted of the crime so I
just wanted to know had you talked to
him at all have you heard anything about
this no I definitely haven't you know
I'm just as shocked as you you all you
know I've seen it on the Internet as
well and that's something else I didn't
see coming and you know what we'll
definitely have to see how that unravels
I have no idea what what that's about
not someone you've stayed in touch with
no not and not in that sense um you know
obviously in the house we all have spoke
but you know I never spoke to him about
this situation
oh yeah so he wasn't he didn't mention
it to anybody it was a complete surprise
day yeah complete surprise I think a lot
of people are kind of shocked by it you
know
yeah well I'm shocked in like sad for
Becca that she you know that this is
kind of happening to her and that she's
gonna have to address it and um okay so
more questions coming in for you
Tonya asked what you thought about Blake
well I think we've said we like Blake so
cool really cool guy we had a great time
while we're at the house he you know he
played football as well in the group
days he was genuine guy we had
conversation so I'm really loving Blake
I'm a different type of personality you
know he's he's a laid-back guy he's
actually very funny as well oh okay well
maybe there's a side of Blake we haven't
seen yet Brian from YouTube says
Kristina if you could be on another
season of The Bachelorette whose season
would you want to be on oh okay is there
anybody well now that we know that
you're off maybe let's ask is there
anybody else from bachelor nation you're
potentially interested in it becomes a
small world where people date each other
quite a lot right right for me
personally I had a great time when Becca
season so if I can do it all over again
I would and I felt like I have no
regrets it was fun and you know
hopefully I can you know still keep in
touch with everyone and we'll see where
it goes
could we see you in the Sun in sand of
Mexico no actually I felt like I was
looking for that one-on-one connection
and I definitely enjoyed that and I was
just a once-in-a-lifetime experience and
you know that's really what I was
looking for okay are you dating anybody
now single no I'm single right now yes
follow him on social media your dreams
could come true so yeah we had so much
love for wills and for Blake also want
to talk to you about the villains on
this season Jaime from YouTube said who
is the villain this season well it's an
interesting question because I don't
think you have but do you feel there was
a villain on the season I I'm leaning
more towards like there were some people
causing drama but I don't know if there
was a villain or is Jordan the villain I
love
he was very entertaining yeah he's being
himself and so some people didn't like
that I was the guy in the house who was
more on the you know the calm I was
trying to be cut the club guy and I felt
like if Becca likes it then why is
anyone in the house worried about it I
don't get too caught up in what Jordans
doing it creates a problem when you get
caught up in like what's going on with
the other guys yeah Jordan so let's play
a little bit of this two-on-one date
that Jordan and David had last night
with Becca you know in the middle of the
desert out of bed which when they create
those moments for us I have to say I
didn't I feel like people are hating on
Jordan but I felt like David was just as
much to blame here yeah he was causing
just as many
problems he was talking about Jordan he
was creating issues and it felt like
Jordan sometimes went too far in
defending himself he said a few mean
things but it kind of felt to me like he
was always having to play defense with
Davis yeah from Wow thinking like night
one or night too I just felt like they
just never had the positive energy
towards each other and they just were
back and forth well we were getting one
comment on Facebook asking are you team
Jordan or team David Wow
no I'm not a team in any of them right
now no I was theme Beca time so yeah but
those two they really had it out for
each other and I think the two on one
really show they really had their time
to let it all out what was it like when
David came back from the hospital
because it was a little wild as a fan
watching the show you're hearing one
minute he's in the ICU and then he's
like I'm back wait
are you okay yeah what was that like for
you guys were you surprised that he kept
moving very surprised I did not expect
him to come back but um you know he's a
strong guy and we were just happy that
he was okay you know
yeah that he was able to walk on its own
two feet come in there and say hello and
you know we seen how it goes I mean I've
heard that it was pretty obviously was
in the ICU it was like he was have I
mean how long was he actually out of the
house for he was on the house for quite
a few days
oh really okay okay it seemed faster
watching it so yeah yeah yeah convinced
everything through it within the
two-hour special but yeah he was going
for a few days okay so he comes back and
like was he and pain was he okay well we
pretty much stayed out of the loop for a
few days even after he came back you
know I sand down and just recovering
resting so we keep fighting Jordan okay
I think he came back and he's like I'm
here Rebecca and to annoy Jordan oh yeah
we said what's up Jordan I'm like I know
like why are we still doing this yeah um
Jeanette says that Garret is growing on
her um Tia I would imagine it's not Tia
booth but you know maybe it is says
Jordan was never mean or malicious just
kind of full of himself he's harmless
there were a couple comments he made me
like when it Dave it's like a parents
and stuff like that which I don't love
but
overall Jordan really just liked to talk
about himself didn't he did yeah
sometimes you have those people who just
are really into themselves and you know
I think if Jordan could date anyone he
would date himself a lot of people have
it kind of went viral after night one
that grocery store Joe didn't get enough
time on the show are there any guys when
you're watching it and thinking like you
thought they would get more airtime or
maybe they should get more airtime guys
who are kind of like I don't know like
for example last night I loved watching
John he was so sweet and I felt like all
this guy was really cool with him yeah
are there any like standout guys who
maybe aren't getting their moment who we
could maybe see on paradise get more of
a moment yeah I mean I I think a lot of
the guys could have got more time but I
mean it's it's very hard to condense
everything in all the conversations and
I mean they have to have the highlight
points of what she really enjoyed and
the conversation that went further
I think leo he's one of the guys that
you know you didn't see much of much of
him last night but leo was one of the
funniest guys in the house by far I hope
that he starts to get more time he
definitely got a rose last night yeah
everybody loved that moment I think on
last week when he looked to the camera
after Lincoln said the earth was flat
does Lincoln really think the earth is
flat I don't know I don't know maybe
that could have been for TV or I'm not
sure there have been some very weird
rumors but I mean not only arrest but
some strange rumors about him online
about his bathroom habits have you heard
these no I actually haven't haven't been
looking have him doing my research on on
those guys were there any guys in the
house like who did cuz you live with
these people you know I mean anybody who
had weird like cooking habits or like
was super messy just I don't know what
what do you learn about people when
you're living together in the mansion
okay so I think it seems Ryan the banjo
guy oh yeah he was an interesting guy
yeah I think he slept one time he
overslept one time and missed like the
date card he just missed it or something
something happened on that scene to me
he did he liked to sleep oh okay kind of
a current moment um at least he didn't
fall to the bunk bed I guess I mean did
he really David he just fell out he just
rolled out or what yeah I mean it was
I'm from when I
member I just remember just he fell and
we are heard and we just ran too you
know you like hurt and fall in the night
and ran to the world yeah and what is it
like blood his face everywhere it was it
was a it wasn't really a funny thing it
was just kind of like it was a very
serious moment so yeah and so we you
know had the paramedics come but we were
all very kind of shocked that that
happened and just huge making sure he
was okay
really yeah I have to say I'm kind of
surprised it hasn't happened before
like people been sleeping in those bunk
beds for years but if somebody had to be
the first to fall out of it and from
YouTube says who do you think would be a
good next Bachelor well an the tough
thing is we don't know how this season
has come out yet
but I will say I like Blake a lot I
don't know what's gonna happen but we so
we were you mentioned that one-on-one
date that Blake and Becca went on each
he was on set for that and so I got to
meet Blake there and he was just so fun
and sweet I loved him cool guy so he's
like well liked by everyone okay I think
Blake was one of the guys and we're like
yeah if he had a if you had the chance
to become the best or or you know we
never know how this season plays out
aaliyan from youtube says well you are a
former Globetrotter what are you up to
now well you know I live in Los Angeles
and I'm just you know I do entertainment
do commercials and things like that so
I'm just working on my you know my
career at booking jobs I still do slam
dunk contests at Venice Beach and do you
model like could Jordan get you into
models oh yeah I've done some modeling
but now it's a Jordans level towards
that well I gotta give Jordan credit I
you know sometimes people just have jobs
that aren't for real on this show he
really is a Wilhemina model like he has
a profile on their website oh wow that's
awesome Jordans off as we said Jordan
was himself Tonya says I was
disappointed in David he did not handle
the situation right he is still a good
guy well I really want to believe that I
don't think David's a bad guy what's
your take on Dave no I think all the
guys were pretty cool for the most part
I just think they got too caught up into
each other's own problems versus dealing
with Becca so I felt like the two on one
they they really should have taken that
more seriously and you know focus on her
versus each other well how have you guys
all stayed close like a lot of the time
you know again
live with people everybody just becomes
good friends the bromance is like is
everybody still talking to each other
and stay in tight after the season yeah
I think these guys have you know they're
the group chats and you know and we all
travel so you know if we're in the same
city hey let's link up and yeah at that
time well so overall then if you're on
like the group chat how do people react
to the Lincoln thing was everybody's
shocked about it is he on the group chat
yeah well I'm actually not even in the
group chat because I don't have an
iPhone so they don't like they don't
like the green they don't like the green
mess that Android ball may be in trouble
with that okay but no we haven't really
connected as far as what happened during
that time or analyze that okay well I
guess we're gonna find out when we do
men tell all
I will see how that's handled you know
it's not the first I mean we on Rachel
Lindsey season Li Garrett and his tweets
had to be addressed on the show of
course but it is it's unfortunate well
you know this is a great question to end
on I love this Sarah on YouTube she says
what is your favorite thing about Becca
favorite thing you know actually she was
very funny she was kind of silly side
when we play football
me and her actually had a headstand
contest Friday and I beat her I hope
they could play that one day that it'd
be there my headstand contest but you
know she was a just energetic you know I
spoke to her and I'm like how do you do
it there's all these guys in the house
and she's like I just want to get to
know everyone that I can have this time
with so you know other things sometimes
you just pass a guy like no no but you
know she actually was genuine and she's
here for the work she was there for the
right reasons she was taken time all
right awesome
well Kristen thank you for taking the
time to be with us and everybody thanks
so much for watching we have a new recap
a roses and roses a recap of
Bachelorette going up on YouTube today
and we loved getting all of your
comments and make sure to follow Kristen
on social media and let us know what you
think as the season of The Bachelorette
continues have a great day everybody
[Music]
you